[Music]
just kidding
the friends at Apple taught me that
how's everyone doing tonight it's like
2:00 in the morning
you did it I just thinking the backstage
they have like a makeup station and the
sound guy was like oh do you need makeup
and I'm like I think I've got enough
going on here how do i how do I look do
I look good yeah of course I do anyway
so along with that and the layout and
aggressiveness of this slide I think
that should set a tone for the rest of
the talk
so despite with Laurie said in his talk
this morning I'm not talking about
webassembly I think that they were they
misread the schedule that's actually
Max's talk which was moved to tomorrow
so please check it out I'm here today to
talk about package managers I'm just
kidding oh oh I'm before it before I go
on I know this counts towards the time
in my talk where is Keith person can I
keep here oh yeah happy birthday case
well and why we're clapping let's get a
round of applause to the organizers
volunteer speakers sponsors awesome
thank you so much for having me tonight
which was supposed to be a talk I had
called JavaScript considered useful but
then I saw that the conference schedule
had my talk this late and so I switched
things up a bit so thank you for
sticking around this late for the first
episode and maybe last of my new hit
show JavaScript after dark night time is
a time to reflect on the past day like
did we feel productive did we meet our
goals of meeting new people saying hi to
old friends not drinking too much coffee
who here drink too much coffee did we
learn some new stuff from the talks
today like how capitalism is bad right
Wow
it's also a time to reflect on those
moments we can't ever take back whose
flashbacks keep us up at night important
and impactful meaningful moments like
this time a woman asked me in lower
Manhattan three years ago at that red X
there where the Chase Bank was and I
said I didn't know but it turns out we
were literally in front of a Chase Bank
think about it every night tonight we're
going to reflect on some just as
insomnia inducing past and present
moments of j/s the language the
community and me tonight I am your tall
shadowy figure hovering above you over
sleep paralysis now we're not going to
reflect on the birth of JavaScript
twenty-three years ago there's like a
wealth of content online you can read
about how it came to be and it really
wasn't even the most exciting thing to
happen in 1995 that of course goes to
space hogs debut album resident
alien shouts out if you're into British
glam-rock if not get into it oh is this
also released what's the story Morning
Glory around that time but that's
probably just as uninteresting to me
tonight as the JavaScript origin story I
bet you didn't think that someone from
outside the world of package managers
would be bringing the hottest takes to
the JavaScript conference but here we
are the only year in the past that we
are going to talk about is probably the
most impactful to all of us tonight and
that is 10 years ago and that is 2009 I
know a lot of math so what were
JavaScript the community and I up to in
2009 and have we all collectively grown
and clone up since so let's explore in
2009 JavaScript had just about started
getting used to actually being useful
both for normals and nerds the iPhone
had only been out for about two years so
the idea of JavaScript and everyone's
pockets was real but it was still in its
infancy not a lot of people like knew it
had been about four years since Ajax had
come about and I think stronger than
dirt is a pretty good bar to reach for
scripting languages in part two Ajax web
2.0 was evolving from simple user
interactions like shitpost blog comments
to actual collaboration and real-time
shitposting comments with the release of
google wave wave pioneered the
operational transforms algorithm that
most well-working collaborative
environments used today like glitch so
honestly haters of Google Wave can eat
it
github and Stack Overflow are about a
year old and the most popular JavaScript
questions from that year we're a
reflection of both the languages youth
and complexity which nearly matched that
of the social construct of time which to
this day we still have issues with and
JavaScript prototype Script oculus Joe
John J career all a few years old
already
it's about the user-interface baby I'm
sorry I cringed whenever I I hear that
for the client-side there wasn't much
besides the cringy taglines and logos
entirely exciting or dramatic going on
and to be fair this is the year before
backbone was released so there was no
real framework wars in sight yet it
would be another year before Steve Jobs
would release his viral YouTube video
slash open letter thoughts on flash
by the way flash ends of life next year
so rich people and blogging mails
weren't quite yet talking about html5 is
as if it were like an actual brand new
language ready to solve literally every
problem yet so it was a simpler softer
more down-to-earth time for the document
object model and those of us [ __ ]
around with it but that's not to say the
2009 was without excitement or even
conflict in drama
shouts out to the tc39 panel earlier it
looked a lot different back then looks a
lot different last year t 79 was having
a rough time coming to a resolution to a
debate that I will summarize as I do
most drama in this community as
grown-ups fighting on blogs instead of
saying it to their faces blogs for the
unfamiliar we're how people used to put
long threads of tweets into a single
page by the way our AP and CC 39 for
those who missed the panel earlier which
was a great panel it's a technical
committee to whom large companies pay
upwards of seventy K US dollars to join
and vote on what does or doesn't change
with JavaScript the language it appears
some in 2009 the committee was pulling a
weekend at bernie's with the pure and
applied math icon John von Neumann fun
facts no I'm an invention merge sort
which is the second-best sorting
algorithm next to George sort of course
I don't know maybe maybe this is what CC
39 was actually fighting about whatever
it was it was
honestly one of the least interesting
things I read about and trying to learn
what was going on 2009 but to be fair
there was a lot of competition and being
interesting remember Google Wave came
out that year and by the way it's it's
hard not to see some irony and that the
Year collaboration was disrupted some
dudes from large companies building
those collaboration tools had a hard
time collaborating with each other maybe
that's the hardest problem in computer
science but if you stare directly into
the Sun you may find it interesting that
the resolution of this particular
conflict was the committee renaming atma
script 3.1 to ACMA script fifth edition
well being a version 1.9 points is a
huge deal back then it only pales in
comparison to several years later when
CC 39 I guess had like another conflict
and resulted by bumping up the version
2009 points obviously an homage to the
2009 renaming numerologist should be all
over this [ __ ] most of the news about
javascript 2009 was not about javascript
but about browsers who were all
allegedly the best Stallman was mad
about open source and yeah some things
haven't changed company is tracking us
so you know we knew we were warned but I
think most of you this room would agree
that the actual exciting news within the
JavaScript can in that year four
developers at least was the founding of
the common jeaious module specification
and a few months later at the initial
release of nodejs yeah whoo yeah whoo
so like 2009 was like a growth spurt
year our youthful and in complex
JavaScript was finally going through
puberty you know who wasn't going
through puberty me
I was 24 years old in 2009 and if you go
off my tweets from that year alone I was
dealing with excruciating wisdom tooth
pain which I couldn't afford to fix
because I was broke as [ __ ] so I took
recreational drugs to curb the pain
instead and express myself on the
Internet while doing so I was into Rob
Thomas and deleting the internet before
that became cool and I freaking loved
Yahoo pipes shouts out well would
probably surprise you is I was actually
not writing much JavaScript I was in
graduate school working on my master's
in computer science and my last year of
courses is virtually all mathematics and
we're not writing pages and pages of
pure math quite beautifully I must add I
was programming in our who here knows
our so for those of you unfamiliar with
art it's similar to us very
self-explanatory I had a lot of odd jobs
back then but my most fulfilling was
teaching non technical college students
how to use excel at 7:00 a.m. I love
this review from rate my presses because
it said the class topics themselves are
really boring but it's not like she
invented Microsoft Office and forced it
upon us now I did not invent Microsoft
Office but I did create the curriculum
so yeah 7:00 a.m. sometimes I had no
idea what stackoverflow or github were
and those sites are probably not even
actively considering me a part of their
target core demographic I was a young
white woman studying computer science
stats and linear algebra and estate
school in New Jersey in 2009 that was
like the conventional path to becoming a
software engineer if you were broke
living on your own and the only person
in your family to go to college I don't
think that there are any web developer
boot camps in 2009 and most higher
education software engineering focused
programs at least in the states were
using Java and C++ and still to this day
to teach programming
we send an applicable level so my
sparing usage of JavaScript was copying
and pasting from cool sites and blogs
I'd like to look at and follow using
Google Reader remember I do Googlers in
here I remember what you did also I
wanna shouts out to my old D&D crew
Brian Brennan's here I forgot to take my
D&D Handbook and my glittery makeup bag
full of dice out of this shop before I
took it and the that elephant says PHP
PHP is JavaScript with question marks I
did a lot of really shitty part-time
freelance web design and development yes
design with like a wide range of low or
no paying clients and most of that
development work was written in PHP
which is way prettier than the designs I
was expected to come up with so yeah my
then boyfriends friends dad's real
estate company who didn't pay me learned
about DMCA takedowns that year Joan
Osborne grammy-nominated singer
performer of what if God was one of us
Fame hated what I decided but it's fun
and one of the guys who wrote the story
that the movie baby geniuses adapted
friend and that guy was at he's actually
sick as [ __ ] but he also hated what I
designed but as my friend lon Ingram
once said when his kid vomited on him
tough but fair
I'd even tweet about JavaScript until
2010 far from helpful I should to be
purchasing this services for me to me
the programming community let alone a
JavaScript community didn't really exist
program in general didn't exist outside
of the classroom and maybe in a couple
of IRC channels and this one mailing
list I participated in about my favorite
operating system opensolaris the poor
went out for that like wild tc39 was
arguing over what they were are whatever
they're arguing about 2009 Oracle was
buying Sun Microsystems
microsystems and so with that was the
the end of the opensolaris project and I
was heartbroken and to this day I am
still pissed at Oracle you know what
also died in 2009 geo cities yeah so
this may seem hella dramatic but at this
time I was basically watching everything
that was important to me about open
source of building the web being
destroyed and a very tiny bubble that
was very far and extremely different
from the bubble I am in today which is
the JavaScript community the JavaScript
community what many of us call the
communities what we see here tonight you
know we think of Jay s Kampf the family
conferences and J's coffee you this
conference is mentioned in the mornings
intro started in 2009 in response to or
after the inaugural Jays comp us earlier
that year you may recognize the
organizers well it baby on
I like that Yan grew his beard over the
past ten years so that he can die at
pink just for us tonight
Malta where are you I see you in the
pink there I can't believe you spoke at
your own conference that's like wearing
a Green Day shirt - a Green Day concert
I mean it's badass but I don't know also
you know something up making fun of amp
and this talk so so wild to me there was
no community it definitely did exist
somewhere and allegedly it was rock and
roll and I remember I love rock and roll
so like why didn't anyone tell me about
this I mean if you look at this image
and you look at the earlier a couple of
years images and that like intro you'll
probably realize that I wasn't part of
the core target demographic of not only
maybe the tools that came out in 2009
but these events and and that's not
meant to be shade that's reality
in 2009 it was very hard to see someone
like me in the audience of an event like
this let alone onstage visible and
admired by the tech community
also these conferences were and are as
they're expensive as hell and and I
don't know about the rest of y'all who
who at least like went to college but
the predatory textbook industry ate up
whatever so-called disposable income I
had plus I'm here to buy weed because my
wisdom teeth were hurting just kidding
I've never done a crime but today two
thousand nine plus ten equals 2019 I can
better support myself and others and and
not only am i actively part of the
JavaScript community I'm literally right
here on stage at the tenth jeaious
coffee you or at least the tenth year
that they've had it so congrats to the
organizers and everyone for such a long
run let's give another round of applause
[Applause]
what a wild ride this past ten years
have been for one I don't have wisdom
teeth anymore so that's great news
unless great news I also don't have
Google Reader Google Wave or Yahoo pipes
ten years I was mad at Oracle today the
feeling is mutual this is a tweet by an
Oracle employee after this conference
announced my speaking and please don't
find this person and give them [ __ ] he's
correct
Jay's copy you is better than this using
a future Rama gift to represent me this
conference will be hearing from my
lawyers and by the way it needs to be
said that me making fun of Oracle owning
the JavaScript trademark is not punching
down because unlike Larry Ellison I
don't want to [ __ ] Island with a
volcano on it so he's gonna be just fine
javascript the name though maybe it's
not unreasonable to worry about that
capitalism is bad so yeah not only do I
worry about her write a lot of
JavaScript I'm now an exec at the most
one of the most exciting startups in the
JavaScript ecosystem glitch calm ya
shuts out
I get to lead and work with some of the
best engineers designers and business
people in the world and we're all
working together to make it so that
everyone who uses the web can create the
web and it's been wild to start to see
that happen and not only is it happening
but people are building apps on glitch
that I couldn't imagine would be
possible within the confines of the
browser and this beloved portable
dynamic language we use like I'm not
even saying hard to see like ten years
ago
like I couldn't imagine this stuff or
double stuff five years ago things like
virtual reality and motion detection the
browser we have a cool web VR starter
kit and we've been working with Mozilla
I'm making cool demos and like in the
browser
like who'd a thunk machine learning in
music shouts out to Monika Dean coolest
goos really awesome stuff with magenta
Jas I have people asking and answering
important existential questions about
the new metal group Evanescence the
answer is going under there best song
and I also see people on a more serious
note you know extending other services
and even content management systems like
WordPress with their Gutenberg editor so
it's sick game devs are not only making
games on glitch but they're building
them in a way so that those who don't
typically design and build games can do
so with their own levels and that is
also super sick speaking to get games
that quiz game that Mark owns some have
been playing is a glitch up but also
like under the hood we have a powerful
hell collaborative editor written in
JavaScript that runs in the browser that
lets everyone write JavaScript and other
languages collaboratively and even view
server-side javascript in the browser so
like the scale of access to writing
javascript in 2019 among all the editors
is matched only by the access to
learning it this year you know there are
boot camps now and there's on
learning and they're expanding the
options and opportunities for people to
enter the community and industry even
the books I see about JavaScript today
show that not only is the community
growing in number developers and
technologies but the backgrounds of
those using javascript is changing I
want to give a shout out to Daniel
Schiffman of coding trained awesome
series Nick Morgan writing the
JavaScript for kids book and all the
like awesome great initiatives like
black girls code giving like people
getting people of all ages and
backgrounds into our communities so that
we all collectively can not only build
the web together but build like an
ethical web that solves the problems
that we all actually have and solves
everyone's problems not just a core
group people are just asking you know
anymore how to use javascript to
redirect a page or figure out the name
of the month
they're asking JavaScript they're asking
how to use JavaScript to tell a story
with data around gun violence and
political activism and we're learning
and teaching literature and art using
the language so shouts out to Pro
Publica Color of Change awesome
organization my large son Angus Kroll
for writing is Hemingway wrote
JavaScript and then Vaart Institute is
my own project it's like the at the
drive-in aside projects like on
indefinite hiatus and fronted by a huge
dingus and not only does javascript the
language look different the people
writing and talking about JavaScript do
too so shouts out to all of my fellow
speakers as a savanna round of applause
rub and the emcee is
[Applause]
and don't you dare let anyone tell you
that the diversity and who is writing
all this code and the brilliance of what
is being made with it are a coincidence
it's not and we have a lot more work to
do to make it actually diverse and
inclusive and we can only imagine how
awesome and how brilliant the things
coming out of this language will be when
we are at the point and beyond that we
could say that
anyway 2009 was a wild year but 2019 is
[ __ ] lit which makes it incredibly
hard to imagine what could be in store
for us in 2029 but I flew all the way
out here so let's give it a go these are
my hopes and dreams for 2029 but first
you might have noticed my avatar on the
website I gave them one that had my face
and the skeleton zoomed in I was told
that the reason my conference headshot
is zoomed in on the skeleton is because
of AI which means we're all going to die
but honestly in 2029 a significant
amount of not majority a code will be
written by machines and that shouldn't
be surprising with all the talk about
artificial intelligence in this industry
this has been planned for decades if you
read any early text books on artificial
intelligence like the people who've like
created that idea did it's like machines
would write our code for us like I don't
know why we like Korean work for
ourselves like machines can do it and
and we've already boiler plated and
automated a lot via command-line
interfaces which is rad but we're going
to need some nice slick graphical user
interfaces to bring that development to
the masses much like some of our
favorite operating systems did for
computing in general so that's the cycle
we're entering into now and because we
need gooeys there's a lot of abstraction
and design challenges that come with it
so that means that those specializations
we saw starting to disappear of the past
10 years
like you know like content and style as
separate concerns from interaction I
think that those things are going to
become more discrete again and with that
like the role front-end and back-end
will become rarely used on ironically as
much as the phrase close to the middle
is I think we're gonna see a lot more
specialization in our community and
front and back will be replaced with UI
an L ai IOT I hope they come up with
another phrase in IOT I don't like that
too many letters VR I I would say
hobbyist or maker but I think that's
also kind of like the the maker movement
is still quite misogynist because women
have been doing crafts and yarn and all
that sort of [ __ ] for years so hopefully
there's a better word for that that
doesn't sort of bring that patriarchal
theme into things but yeah ways
specialize and that's not to say that
there won't be a space or generalist
because we're going to need even more of
them to mentor coach and educate new and
seasoned specialists so I think like the
thing that we need to worry about and
I'm seeing it already in our community
is the gap in value and pay of educators
in the industry yeah shouts not to my
teachers and not like the engineers who
teach on the side because it's extra
money and they don't really care about
the people that they're teaching no
anyway I can't go on these tangents and
look at people mad that gap by the way I
think should be can be filled with all
the money Microsoft is spending on
trying to figure out who horse jeaious
is just saying
Ryan's all will be doing a mistakes I
made making D note or I'm sorry Ryan if
you watch this video you're a treasure
please don't hate me but I'm right
Microsoft is going to shut down github
and BS code in their master plan to get
us back to using Microsoft Word to build
HTML pages like nature intended
and because word doesn't allow
JavaScript all y'all who are like
JavaScript is considered harmful folks
will finally be happy but then you'll
realize your brand has become obsolete
so sorry about that
maybe echo will update their website
design also you feel that the trademarks
down there that's an update if any of
you are here still I want to propose
some hot new trendy dark modes or an old
classic hot dog stand even better
Navy and 2029 will have designed and
implemented a more diverse and inclusive
way to evolve the language then leaving
it up to only large english-speaking
corporations who can afford not only a
seat at the table but the flight and
hotel to whoever that table keeps moving
around to now
given the number of people in this room
and my background in both statistics and
getting yelled at on the internet I will
say it's highly probable that some of
you are thinking gen why are you
complaining about diversity when you
just said this event is more diverse
than it was 10 years ago
and yes Uncle Bob from my extreme white
woman perspective we're doing a bit
better this decade when it comes to DNI
but I predict in hope that by continuing
and evolving this work in 10 years the
need for diversity scholarships will
have dwindle more than made obsolete by
the fact that companies will value all
of their employees enough to sponsor
their being a part of these events or at
the very least people will not complain
on Twitter about people of color having
their own space at these events
[Applause]
just a reminder we are living in a
misogynist and white supremacist Society
and that plays into a lot of the stuff
that's happening over the next ten years
in a I don't want to like slip that
under the rug so these are hopes and
dreams and I'm hoping that more people
are involved and more diverse people are
involved so that we can sort of undo the
damage and like prevent that any way
that's like an aside off script I can
talk for hours about that but I think
another thing is that all of us
community organizers will have hopefully
evolved the conference experience so
that yeah [ __ ] yeah are they playing
foosball are they getting excited about
foosball shaking my head anyway yeah I
think that will help make it so that all
people can still know the community
exists and feel like they're a part of
it even if they're like I was in 2009
which was too broke to travel and or to
loss to know what I was supposed to be
looking for and I predict that a lot of
people writing code in ten years if not
the majority people brain containers
will not be developers by trade and so
we need to welcome them to this
experience as well as well as tc39
whatever hopefully non-corporate
depressional group is running the show
and it's been said that this will be the
last chance coffee which in the wake of
my microsoft word prediction I'm not
surprised but much like every conference
so I think that they'll probably just
skip a year or two and then keep going
again for years to come just like I'm
thinking like I think this might be my
last JavaScript talk but like I said
that a few years ago and then I came
back you know
jay-z said he wasn't making music
anymore and then he came back I don't
know I just think that's something like
this is too magical and beautiful thing
to give up this like ability to bring
different people together to learn and
grow with each other it won't run quite
the same this conference though and it
shouldn't because again like what the
language and community
look like is rapidly changing so you
know those of you here running companies
and popular projects in the ecosystem I
want you to take note of that dynamic
changing I think it's becoming hella
evident today and and and not only that
not only are more companies and our
ecosystem going to have to live by the
value that all people matter more than
the tech we're building but the survival
of their business will depend on their
being accountable and honest to those
values you know they're staffed by and
used by the community and so those of us
running companies in that space needs to
like walk the walk
sprint even more than than talking the
talk yeah I mean I sit aside I'm just
thinking a lot about like CJ's talk it's
been really hard to witness what's been
going on at npm because like a glitch we
were you know we talked about like we're
trying to get everyone to be able to
build the web and our product is very
like focused on people and it just sucks
when like someone in the ecosystem just
like [ __ ] up something and it sets the
rest of us who are trying to do good
work back and and that's fine we were
ready to the work we're we're here we're
here for the fight like we're gonna do
it and we're gonna win like we're
counting on it but I I'm just hoping
that you all still you all question
companies and ask questions and keep us
honest and hold us accountable because
some of us like wanna do you right we're
trying we're trying really hard and and
while Tech is already political in 2029
I predict there will be significantly
fewer cowards pretending it's not
as for me I don't know where I see
myself in ten minutes let alone ten
years besides of course hotter and
smarter let's be honest thank you where
I see myself in the future has always
been my hardest problem in computer
science like I know where I'm at now and
that's like living a life and in a world
that I never could have imagined ten
years ago let alone two years ago three
months before I joined glitch I was
exploring how to quit tack because I
fell really ill and I just couldn't
manage going to work every day miserable
and also physically being miserable and
one of those things had to give and that
was tech and then fortunately an
opportunity came around and I ended up
at fog Creek and a glitch and that's all
great include but I could never like see
that path happening and it's very scary
when you enter a space even someone
who's been in the game for as long as me
and not knowing what's ahead of you like
not having any visibility you know it
took a lot of like hitting roadblocks
earning a couple of degrees and like
dodging obstacles writing lines of code
and where it's about code getting yelled
at on the internet on the regular and
just like a [ __ ] ton of work for me to
get to where I am today and it wasn't a
direct repeatable path becoming a woman
in leadership and I'm not confident that
such a path is available for anyone else
let alone myself to continue you know
somebody might happen and in three
months or six months I might be like you
know what something's got to give
I gotta go back to teach and excel at
6:00 a.m. or 7:00 a.m. or the [ __ ] it
was I'm not a morning person anymore I
don't want that to happen but I predict
or at least hope that with like the work
we're all doing like all of us in this
room and helping everyone on the web
create the web that our community in
2029 will be more visible and accessible
as well as the definition of success for
individuals more and different people
will not only get a say in how our
language evolves but they'll get time
onstage they look at the safety that
comes with being valued and fairly paid
I think that or hold that they'll be
able to see themselves continuing on
that path and reaching their ideal
destination that they're not just sort
of walking blindly like I feel I am
myself today and I think with that
they'll hopefully be a little more
confident in coaching other generations
and types of coders to reach their ideal
destinations as well and I think a lot
of prominent this will marginalize
people in this industry no have have
many stories like this to tell but you
know one day a woman came up to me and
was like I really look up to you I
follow you on twitter I'm like sorry and
she's like I want to like beat you in
two years and I'm like girl I beat me in
two years and I came and tell you how to
be me in ten years and so that's what
I'm hoping will change it and I hope
that path will include building like
awesome apps that solve everyone's
problems I hope it includes leading a
team of the greatest engineers in the
world and you know even flying thousands
of miles to shitpost Larry Ellison a
volcano on the islands look it up if i
play my cards right and if y'all let me
play them I think that I'll be doing all
of those things still maybe not flying
miles to shitpost Larry Ellison that's
kind of like a one-and-done thing I
think that maybe I'll be helping some
glitch employee work on their dot docx
confit you talk where they showcase all
the awesome apps that are rad community
made that year and we asked our
community what they would be making a
2029 and it was things like facilitating
farming
supplying and exchanging energy quantum
computing challenging the social
construct of time
facilitating the consumption of news in
a social media dystopia and maybe even
just simply making websites I know that
my hair will probably be all gray which
will look sick as hell I hope my wisdom
teeth don't grow back I don't know
climate change it's like you never know
what's gonna happen anti-vaxxers like
but I'm pretty confident that every
night I'll be lying wide awake just like
I've done for years reflecting on that
one moment where I told that woman in
front of the bank that I did not know
where the Chase Bank was maybe the Sun
will burn out thank you anyway
thanks for sticking around for
JavaScript after dark I'm Jenn Schiffer
you're all awesome smash those links
please like and subscribe and I'll see
you on glitch comm thank you
[Applause]
[Music]